[Music]
Taron I want you to do well I want you
to have a great life
I love you but we cannot see Hawaii that
you can live under this roof if you're
gonna fundamentally go against the grain
of our beliefs
Jaron tell me the truth that's all I
think about men I don't know why I'm so
sorry your parents signed you up for a
program to fix you but here you are a
perfectly normal very healthy teenage
boy they're gonna do things for you you
want to say welcome to the refuge
program from you cannot be born a
homosexual this is alive it's your
choice
no fake it till you make it become the
man you are not save yourself Karen God
will not love you the way that you are
is this what you want
who's gonna strike this demon down sir
I'm having a tough time I'm gonna give
you some advice tell them whatever they
want to hear
play the part unless it really think you
can change artisanal on to what you
going through right now is just a moment
unknown yes a moment I love God and I
love my son for your father it's a
little more complicated we are not
finished I am because you won't listen
your father is sitting here telling how
you hate him I'm not gonna pretend I
hate my father I don't hate my father
then where is all this anger come
because you're making me angry they say
sometimes you gotta hurt a child in
order to help them but a mother knows
when something is
I don't want to pretend anymore I've had
to ask myself and God if I'm ready to
lose you
Oh
watch it over
[Music]